this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up friends michael here now at
wisecrack we love therapy getting to
monologue to a captive audience for an
hour straight check overcoming lingering
demons from that time our mom called us
an unplanned miracle check in short we
truly believe that therapy can change
people's lives yours truly included and
therapy has never been more widespread
socially acceptable or accessible which
is great because a lot of people really
need it indeed in 2018 one in five
american adults experienced a mental
health issue and that was before the
modern plague it turned us all into
agoraphobes but lately we've seen the
mega rise of apps promising
psychological transformation in just
five minutes a day and this leaves us
wondering what is therapy really for and
are we asking therapy and ourselves to
do too much let's explore in this
wisecrack edition on therapy can it save
us all
but before we really get into it i want
to tell you about this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn keeps your
data secure everywhere you go on the
internet thanks to their secure
protocols and uncrackable encryption one
of my favorite perks of surfsharkvpn is
the way it keeps my location totally
private which is a huge help when it
comes to things like buying plane
tickets for instance you can connect
your secure surfsharkvpn to other vpns
around the world and then you can easily
track down the best deals available and
speaking of the rest of the world these
connections also let you watch all the
movies and tv you like especially
content that hasn't been released in
your country yet all of your favorite
devices are included in a single
subscription including your laptop
android amazon fire stick playstation
and more plus you can still use your
favorite apps too like chrome and
firefox get started by clicking the link
in the description and using the promo
code wisecrack when you do you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus three extra
months for free so go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show now the stigma surrounding
therapy and seeking help for mental
health issues has dissolved
significantly over recent years this is
unequivocally great news especially when
you consider how mental health used to
be treated in the good old days which
definitely were old but definitely were
not good early psychiatric treatment
typically involved confining patients to
lunatic asylums with horrible living
conditions often patients were
sterilized women could be kept in
asylums purely on their husband's
recommendations why would your husband
do that he said something about me
participating in some flag burning at a
local suffragette protest he was not
happy with my decisions and found me
generally annoying lgbtq plus folks and
other marginalized people were also
often considered pathological and
typically super churchy people assumed
all these issues stemmed from demonic
possession
so
that's not good in short psychiatry was
more about punishing folks who failed to
conform to social norms with a heavy
dose of sexism homophobia racism and
eugenics then in 1895 everybody's
favorite goatee guy sigmund freud teamed
up with joseph brewer to publish studies
on hysteria which championed the talking
cure to help work through psychological
trauma you know the one patient lies on
the couch and talks at length to their
analyst about all their deepest thoughts
and feelings importantly freudian
psychology was less about offering
practical fixes for your problems and
more about understanding your negative
thought patterns neuroses and so on his
goal was to help make the unconscious
conscious which could eventually help
improve people's mental health
psychotherapy became increasingly
popular in the u.s around world war ii
and then boomed in the 1950s in what
scholar daniel p kaminski calls the age
of affluence and anxiety this was due to
the intersecting phenomena of the
post-war economic boom with the high
numbers of world war ii soldiers with
ptsd then referred to as shell shock as
well as widespread fear about nuclear
weapons as kamensky notes this era of
therapy saw the origin of an emphasis on
patients doing the work as he puts it
psychoanalysts advised patients that the
traditional american value of hard work
needed to be applied to therapy as well
as to their personal pursuit of
happiness this was a big change from
freud having you articulate traumatic
memories while half asleep on a tiny
couch at the same time
psychology-infused self-help books
boomed in popularity and they were
usually about pulling yourself up by
your bootstraps and tackling your
maladaptive emotional responses a
positive psychologist pushed the idea of
self-improvement and reaching your full
potential if it sounds kind of like
motivational speaking that's because it
basically was but what was really the
purpose of psychoanalysis according to
kaminsky therapy functioned largely as a
way to lead people into conformity in
particular conformity with america's
booming consumer economy and workforce
as he writes by advocating clearly
defined traditional gender roles and
normative sexuality set in the single
family psychoanalysts helped legitimize
and popularize the american dream good
mental health then was largely defined
as the ability to fit societal standards
surrounding work gender family and so on
one famous psychoanalysis institute the
meninger clinic even explicitly promised
to return its patients to
useful citizenship kamensky writes that
psychoanalysts promised that americans
in therapy could be made to conform with
a high degree of efficiency to the
values of hard work and productivity in
work and in their personal lives in
doing so they reflected and reinforced
industriousness as a key value of
americans so what we have here are three
important aspects of 1950s style therapy
one an emphasis on the patient's hard
work
two conformity to american values and
three becoming a productive member of
society this would only grow more true
in the 60s and 70s as cognitive
behavioral therapy or cbt became all the
rage cbt focuses on recognizing and
rationalizing negative thought patterns
for example if your brain is telling you
that there is a creepy clown hiding in
your car a cbt therapist would ask you
to think critically about the
statistical likelihood of this being so
they'd suggest alternative thoughts like
it's very unlikely that there is a
creepy clown hiding in my car this can
be especially useful after doing uber
pickups the weekend of the clown
convention indeed cbt encourages you to
think critically about your thought
patterns in order to change them it
teaches logical skills to deal with
distressing situations and emotions with
the ultimate goal of significantly
mitigating or even totally eliminating
their impact on your life as journalist
oliver berkman explains cbt is based on
the principle that your distress is
caused by your irrational beliefs and
it's within your power to seize hold of
those beliefs and change them again we
see emphasis on the individual doing the
work with the help of a therapist to
ultimately overcome their issues this
contrasts against the freudian method of
understanding unconscious drives in
order to release repressed experiences
and emotions notably while freud's
methods were expected to take many years
cbt is considered a short-term method at
least by insurance companies typically
consisting of 5-20 sessions and to be
clear it's not the individual
therapist's fault that you're only
allowed to have 10 sessions a year or
whatever they're just playing by the
rules set by private insurance companies
and no doubt cbt can be enormously
helpful for things like phobias and
sleep disorders but it's been critiqued
for offering cheap fast solutions with
some dissenting therapist arguing that
it pushes a think yourself to wellness
narrative
cbt undoubtedly has changed tons of
lives again
yours truly
still there's a growing pile of research
suggesting that it's not a
one-size-fits-all solution particularly
when it comes to depression so we
started with a long-term commitment
based on a good relationship between
therapist and patient centered around
exploring the unconscious and we're
trending toward therapy as a self-led
bite-sized course and if you don't have
the time insurance or resources to
afford that well now silicon valley has
an answer therapy but like make it an
app you've likely already seen them
meditation apps breathing exercise apps
mood trackers and self-led therapy apps
for just about any mental health issues
we're also offered mindfulness apps like
headspace which promises to reduce your
stress and improve your sleep in just
three minutes a day it's kind of like
therapy for people without the time or
money to be emotionally unzipped by a
professional twice a month ah
i unzip me and undoubtedly these
platforms have made mental health care a
lot more accessible which is great and
online therapy has been proven to have
real benefits for people struggling with
depression text-based therapy also adds
an element of anonymity which can be
great for people who struggle to talk
about their mental health what's more
subscriptions for mental health apps can
save people tons of money compared to
conventional therapy which makes
high-end gym memberships look cheap this
can be a lifesaver especially when we
consider that poverty is a major fact in
anxiety depression and substance abuse
issues and that lack of access to mental
health services is the root of the
mental health crisis in the u.s
importantly though many of these apps
rely on cbt boasting that their use of
the model will help you stop feeling
anxious depressed stressed or unable to
sleep and the marketing of cbt on these
apps exacerbates the one-size-fits-all
mentality that people critique the
method for in the first place turning
something as multi-faceted and personal
as mental healthcare into uber but for
your unconscious mind this raises an
important question by pushing convenient
apps to help manage mental health issues
rather than increasing access to and
funding for therapy are we as a society
putting too much pressure on people
struggling with mental health issues to
understand themselves and guide
themselves through their own recovery
with apps we've seen the idea of doing
the work increasingly become about doing
the work alone with apps the onus is
often entirely on the individual to
actively engage with and work through
their problems fittingly the apps are
also tailor-made for a gig economy when
everybody is working multiple jobs with
no time to fully commit to working on
their mental health but hey at least you
can dip into five minutes of therapy in
between doordash deliveries right this
only exacerbates another existing
problem in cognitive behavioral therapy
it's historic failure to address the
systemic issues that often contribute to
individual mental health issues you
might say be taught how to manage the
stress of living in poverty or anxieties
about the unstable job market and
economy but being able to manage these
doesn't change these circumstances
you're still facing down the
possibilities of not being able to
afford dinner or find a new job now
you've simply learned not to be as
worried about it and thus are able to be
a higher functioning member of society
workplace counseling and support options
illustrate the tension between solving
individual versus systemic problems
perfectly employee assistance programs
or eaps began in the late 30s and early
40s to help identify workers whose
struggles with alcoholism were making
them less productive if you're
struggling at work whether due to
depression or stress you might be
offered counseling which often comes
with homework and self-led regimens to
help you overcome your problems what
appears to be an employer's genuine act
of care could cynically be seen as a
situation where interests collide your
interest in feeling better meets your
employer's interest in seeing you meet
your productivity potential at work feel
the 1950s useful citizen vibes here
importantly eaps typically focus on the
few most obviously struggling workers as
scholars jay barrage and c.l cooper
write the concept of the troubled
employee is at the heart of the eap this
approach can be problematic because it
doesn't consider where those troubled
employees troubles actually come from
which might be the workplace itself this
certainly seems true in cases like that
of google which offered counseling to
victims of workplace misconduct
allegedly without bothering to
re-examine the environment that fostered
that misconduct as michael p lighter and
j michael wallen note even when affected
individually focused interventions may
do little more than enable people to
tolerate poorly managed situations and
beyond the microcosm of the workplace
there's no shortage of systemic problems
to be found these days our current
economic realities like the decline of
unions or rising wealth inequality have
even been explicitly linked to rising
mental health issues loneliness is also
on the rise as americans are working
longer hours with fewer support systems
this all leaves people more reliant on
mental health professionals that is when
they can afford the time and cost of
seeing them on top of that job
insecurity due to the gig economy lack
of long-term contracts and fewer
opportunities for promotion can also
contribute to your risk of developing
mental health issues systemic economic
issues like childhood poverty can also
have the same effect but it's not just
economic issues that negatively impact
mental health racism and mass
incarceration have had a staggering
impact on marginalized communities
suicide rates among young black people
have increased by 73
between 1991 and 2017 while accessing
treatment in these communities remains
more difficult than for their white
peers and despite its success in
treating people with anxiety disorders
and other mental health issues modern
cbt therapy still has flaws when it
comes to working with marginalized
people remember it's a highly
individualistic therapy which hinges on
the assumption that a patient has faulty
or irrational thoughts this framing
makes it easy for systemic issues to go
unaddressed for example it's reasonable
that systemic racism sexism or
homophobia in america can beget anxiety
or depression you can't be expected to
positively think your way out of that
reality psychiatrists are still working
on increasing the cultural sensitivity
of cbt so that marginalized groups are
validated while they receive treatment
rather than encouraged to view anxieties
formed around their lived experience as
irrational and lest it sound like we're
criticizing therapists let us quote
scholar james hillman when i criticize
therapy i'm not really out to get
therapists i think they're doing some of
the most important work in the culture
because they are sincerely trying to
pick up the pieces that capitalism
throws into the street indeed therapy is
a difficult profession and getting it
right when you have people's mental
health in your hands can be taxing
what's more therapists can't necessarily
help when it comes to systemic issues
they can only support their patients
within an unjust world and address the
impact it has on them so
where do we go from here scholar micah
ingle argues that as long as people
consider their mental health issues by a
purely medical or cognitive behavioral
model the responsibility will remain on
each individual to get better without
inspiring systemic change but before you
sink into despair know that engel has
some thoughts on what therapy could look
like one interesting alternative he
offers is narrative therapy which helps
people understand and deconstruct the
way they see themselves and why they see
themselves in that way
therapists and patients re-author their
lives to retrace where their
self-perception comes from and address
the social and personal factors that
have impacted them this can mitigate the
effects of systemic problems on patients
by addressing the patient in the context
of the system itself will this or any
other new forms of therapy take off in
our lifetimes it remains to be seen in
the meantime we're stuck with a world
that exposes us to injustice and trauma
and healthcare providers who charge us
hundreds of dollars to even try to feel
better about it while sometimes
neglecting the broader reasons for our
mental health issues but hey at least
you know there's no creepy clown in your
car i mean unless you've been the clown
all along but what do you all think is
modern therapy asking too much of its
patience have mental health apps
revolutionize mental health support or
merely commodified it let us know in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support and don't forget to
listen to our podcast hyper fixate on
that subscribe button like it's your
childhood abandonment issues and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
so
[Music]
you